la mort a frappé l'un vulnérables du
cinéma américain immortel dans ses films
il le paraissait également dans la vie
john wayne vous le savez n'a pas résisté
aux dix années de lutte qu'il menait
contre le cancer
refusant jusqu'au dernier moment les
tranquillisants le cowboy a cédé la nuit
dernière
depuis plusieurs semaines john wayne
avait accepté que les médecins fassent
sur lui des traitements expérimentaux
il est mort entouré de ses enfants
l'ouest est en deuil
michael morrison vient de disparaître et
mickaël morrison c'était un héros de
légende plus connu sous le nom de john
wayne ainsi après une longue lutte le
cow boy d'hollywood est mort à l'âge de
70 ans
il aura tourné plus de 200 films en
quarante huit ans de carrière c'est john
ford qui l'emploie le premier dans des
films muets tels que hangman ça use 1928
ou salle ute 1929 un john ford séduit
par la taille en mètre 91 et la
prestance de ce garçon de leioa mais
c'est raoul walsh qui lui donne son
premier grand rôle en 1930 dans the big
trail où ils jouent pour la première
fois sous le nom de wade
neuf ans plus tard il devient tête
d'affiche à l'âge de 32 ans avec le film
la diligence de john ford
suivront fort apache l'homme qui tua
liberty valance rio bravo et beaucoup
d'autres au total hollywood a gagné
grâce à lui plus de 700 millions de
dollars
celui qu'on surnommait le duke
n'obtiendra qu'un seul oscars en 1969 à
l'âge de 62 ans
pour son interprétation du shérif
cockburn dans true grit d'henry hathaway
mais john wayne c'était plus qu'une
idole c'était la conscience des usa il
incarnait les pionniers de l'histoire
des états unis
et tout le pays s'identifier à lui qu'il
représente un cowboy au grand coeur un
officier de cavalerie ou un soldat de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
d'ailleurs ces rôles et ses déclarations
brutales sur les noirs ou les
communistes son engagement à propos du
conflit vietnamien son soutien à des
homme politiques conservateurs comme ici
richard nixon ou donald reggane
vive allure l'étiquette de réactionnaire
ce à quoi il répondait c'est faux je
suis un libéral aux vieux sens du terme
j'écoute tous les points de vue et je
dessine moi même les libéraux
d'aujourd'hui exigent que vous acceptiez
leur point de vue
c'est pour cela que j'ai été placé
républicain d'extrême droite
contrairement à beaucoup d'américains il
n'aimait pas le goal
il jouait beaucoup aux échecs et aimer
naviguer sur son bateau l'oie sauvage
trois fois marié et trois fois divorcé
john wayne et est père de sept enfants
sur sa tombe il a demandé que l'on grave
3 - espanyol fait au poil pays fort mal
les fort et digne
au revoir monsieur john wayne et bon
voyage au royaume des grandes prairies